why make short films I think for a
director if you're um you're trying to
be a director you you should start off
with a short film and you know it's
cheaper to make and it's a calling card
and producers are more willing to watch
a short film than your feature film so
that like I've gotten more connections
through my short film than I did with my
feature films nobody wanted to watch my
feature films you know when I talk to
Executives or whoever it's so easy to
just be like oh you know after I've had
a meeting with an executive I'm be oh by
the way I also made this short film and
I'll just send you the link you know
check it out it's only 8 minutes and
they'll be okay and they'll check it out
because it's only eight
minutes yeah it's just a great way it's
a great tool that you create for
yourself to um to get into other
opportunities regarding film making
education what do you do to continue it
Master Class Unreal
Engine watching other
movies well for me personally I'm going
to continue with Unreal Engine because I
see that as the future of film making so
I'm going to keep studying because
there's so many aspects of it that um I
still have to learn and and start making
my own projects through that
so but besides that you know I'm always
taking whether it's class or
self-studying um in
screenwriting and just to keep my
writing skills sharp you know I'm
constantly
writing and resources um you know like
watching interviews on film courage um
there's plenty of like podcasts out
there um there's so much material out
there now for learning that for me
personally I don't think people really
need to go to film school and they
probably
shouldn't this was different like maybe
15 years ago right where there weren't
as many resources out there but now
there's there's so much that you can
learn so much just on your own for free
do you think some people though would
benefit from structure because with Film
School don't they force you to have a
thesis project or two and yeah yeah I
think for some people if you really need
that rigid structure um then definitely
do the film school thing but you're also
balancing that with like how much you're
paying for that school right so if you
have a scholarship or something like
yeah if it's free I'll probably do the
same but if it's like okay I got to pay
like you know 100 grand for USC film
school I don't know I don't know is it
worth it like maybe you could use half
of that money and make a a film what
advice would you give to other
filmmakers about making a living as a
filmmaker making a living as a filmmaker
well it's very difficult to make a
living as a filmmaker you're always
going to be doing something
else for a
living um at least in the beginning like
nobody steps out and just becomes a
filmmaker and starts making like a ton
of money right um so everybody needs
something as like a baseline to you know
make an income and and for me you know
what I found out is like once I was able
to get a full-time job that still gave
me the flexibility and freedom to be
creative and do side projects
like I was actually more creative and I
was able to pursue the projects I wanted
to do because I was freed up from having
to worry about making money cuz when I
was doing freelance and trying to be a
filmmaker it was like okay I'm making
I'm writing but I also have to go and Pa
on a film shoot I got to go and like
edit this thing I got to you know be a
grip and those jobs don't pay that well
and it's very hard work you're working
12 or more hours a day and you know
constantly worrying about where's your
next gig so that worry you know is a
blocker for me creatively
so without having to worry about where
my next paycheck is going to come I was
able to really focus and and be more
creative and you know write
better that's a great point and also too
being out in the world you talked about
you like to just be out and explore and
yeah it feeds ideas whereas if you're
just kind of in your own bubble in front
of your computer you don't get as many
ideas yeah yeah and if you're always
working on a film set or something then
all you know is like film
but sure it's great to know how to make
a film
but what is the essence of a film is
still life
so it's better if you have a a job in
something completely unrelated and then
you end up writing a script that's like
set in that kind of world right and then
um when you talk to managers or agents
they're actually more interested because
they're like oh you came from I don't
know a military background oh and you
wrote a military film
script they they immediately see that
you brought authenticity to that script
and now they want to know about you
learn your story and you just have more
to talk about because when you meet
Executives the last thing you want to
tell them is like Oh I'm a filmmaker and
I made this film and that film and all I
know is film making it's like they hear
that all the time so they want to hear a
story that's like oh I I used to be a
detective and this happened and that
happened now they're really interested
in you sure and going back to your
teaching all the stories that you got
from people from all over the world is
yeah sounds so interesting but if you
had just been here in the sort of La
life everybody knows about that are you
as hopeful now as you were after you
made your first feature film about your
film making about being able to tell
stories I'm definitely way more hopeful
now than I was you know 10 years ago
because I mean technology has changed so
much right I mean when I made my first
feature film like we shot on the red
one and at that time the red was like oh
wow a digital cam cinema camera
that's a new thing but now you have like
so many different cameras that are way
more affordable now um so I mean anybody
can you know even the lights are a lot
cheaper you can get different types of
lights that can light everything um and
then especially now with Unreal Engine
I'm so excited about it because I can
make the films that I already wrote a
script for but there would basically be
no way for me to make those unless it
was through a studio but now I can make
those you know myself really as long as
I put a certain number of hours into it
um to still tell those stories and and
there's endless possibilities of the
setting just like the Aesthetics you can
create with that there's no boundaries
really
and do you think too because you said
you kind of went on your own spiritual
journey and and got involved in you said
meditation Buddhism that it also helped
um bring a new Clarity to making movies
yeah definitely um I
think I think
having Clarity and just a sense of You
Know Who You Are and what's important
and and you know why you're doing
something is like really important for
not just for filming for anybody right
um but especially with the film industry
there's a lot of like pressure I feel
like maybe more so with screenwriters
where it's like when are you going to
break through when are you going to do
this um but I think once I kind of got a
little bit more levelheaded and and at
peace with myself of like hey I don't
have to
hit a certain goal for me to feel like
I'm doing something meaningful you know
I can be making a short film that maybe
only like 10 people see but if it's you
know has an impact on them then I am
doing something meaningful and just
through the process of me creating is
Meaningful for myself then that's what
I'm getting the Joy from so I'm not so
much like result orientated but more
like
like why am I doing something right like
I always have to start from
there sure yeah that's great and so it's
not just about like these accolades it's
it's about the meaning behind making
these stories yeah and I and I used to
um identify myself as like Oh I'm a
filmmaker but really it should be more
like I'm just I'm a human being you know
I'm doing other things too I have other
passions um and I make films but if I
don't make films I can write stories I
can you know write poetry I could do
whatever as a creative I think having a
creative Outlet is important but I don't
need to attach my identity as like I'm a
filmmaker and that's all I do why can't
you
stop why can't you stop making
movies I don't know I don't know that's
a great question um I
think I think there's a Drive in me of
creating
and it's like why why does anybody do
anything right it's like it's something
that I find fulfillment in you know like
ever since I was a kid I
like making uh making up worlds and
stories with uh toys so I think that
kind of carried over maybe it's a return
to being a child right like you want to
find that um genuine kind of excitement
or happiness as a kid playing with your
toys maybe I'm searching for that um
maybe I'm just searching for something
to fill a void
maybe and that's where I'm coming to
where it's
like I think I could be okay not making
films anymore if I
[Music]
can find something else to fill a void
writing a story you know I get a lot of
Joy just from writing a script and
reading it and having other people read
it cuz they can experience a story
um so yeah why can't I stop it's just a
human nature it's so you constantly want
more and you're chasing after things
um yeah do you think too with bang bang
because you had such great success with
it I mean you did you fill out both
screenings or or multiple screenings
with numerous people yeah uh the
screenings at the festivals definitely
um even the theaters yeah but not all
the cities like I had a screening in
Austin Texas and only five people showed
up but you
know yeah I think that's a hazing that's
that happens but I mean it sounds like
you you did have like a lot of
enthusiasm for the film I bet that was
very um intoxicating you know especially
at a young age you were 25 25 yeah wow
that's great yeah um it it was
definitely a very fun experience you
know met a lot of people through the
movie um went a lot to a lot of places
doing the screenings and to the
festivals
but yeah you can kind of maybe get lost
in the festivals a little bit because
everybody's praising you um so you feel
like oh yeah I'm the next big filmmaker
but it's like nah like a bunch of people
making films and you know it's like you
just got to plan out your next film but
don't let it get to your head right um
so I think I was definitely dealing with
that a little bit of like oh suddenly
people are looking at me like oh you're
a filmmaker great like yeah you know I
got an award at the LA film F la Asian
film
festival and
um but some of that can be like
detrimental I feel like to someone you
know really why
you know you get um too much too many
compliments and it goes to your head and
then you're not able to look at yourself
critically and then you have a false um
image of
yourself that's amazing though that you
could almost step out of yourself and
see that I mean you could say that's the
the curse of many child actors
unfortunately and it's not always their
fault they've been told you're amazing
this and that and then when that's taken
away how devastating that is you know
yeah so so um I guess you could say that
with anything really you know you could
be the
the I don't know the best um pool
cleaning service and all of whatever and
then if that's taken away yeah then
you're where's your identity after that
and it's like and that's why I was
saying with a failure um is probably the
best thing that can happen to someone
when you fail because you learn life's
biggest lessons from that and you learn
the most about yourself because it's not
about how you celebrate your success
it's more about how you deal with um
your failures you know that kind of
defines your character and and who you
are